coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 36 so
living in New York City for a few months
now I've noticed that a lot of the shops
and restaurants are cash only now this
is generally pretty annoying since as I
imagine a lot of you out there are like
me and I've gotten pretty used to paying
for things with credit or debit cards
the question is why why do so many
establishments only accept cash what's
the incentive for them to be cash only
engine let's say you're buying at the $2
cup of coffee okay so you hand over your
credit card to the barista who swipes it
in her credit card terminal you know
you've seen you see what those things
look like that thing reads the magnetic
strip on the back of the card and sends
the transaction to the acquiring the
acquiring Bank pays the coffee shop two
dollars and the acquiring bank gets
there are two dollars from an issuing
bank think Citibank Wells Fargo Bank of
America which in turn takes the money
from Europe and how this relationship
between the coffee shop and the
acquiring bank is called a merchant
account when the coffee shop opened up
in order to get one of those fancy
credit card terminals it had to set up a
merchant account with an acquiring bank
then it could take your plastic are you
with me so now merchant accounts work in
a lot of different ways but all of them
are going to impose a certain number of
fees on our little coffee shop some of
those fees come from the acquiring bank
but most are coming up through the
system from the issuing bank set by the
credit card companies mastercard visa
discover so when our coffee shop swipes
your card and for every other card it
swipes the issuing bank is going to
charge a small interchange fee most
commonly these fees are set up into
what's called a three-tier pricing
system now a normal swipe of the car
that's going to be first here and you'll
take the smallest charge of all probably
about 1.2 percent of the cost but the
fees don't end a card doesn't get
accepted the first time that's a
nuisance of every swipe no matter what
if it's going to the issuing bank that's
an authorization pick at the end of
every month you have a statement if it
didn't pay enough and fees that month
naught or
we'll just have a little bit more to
make sure you hit your monthly minimum
they settling out all your days
purchases well that's a batch if you
need to use customer service to figure
out what the hell is going on with all
these fees customer service fee okay
so you've had enough you're sick and
tired of the fees you want out of this
credit card thing crook with an early
termination fee sorry to be sure there
are good reasons for charging our little
coffee shop rates and fees there is such
a thing as transaction costs but as you
can probably guess there are serious
abuses as well an enormous antitrust
lawsuit which was filed by 7 million
merchants in 2005 was settled earlier
this year in which the card companies
paid out 7.3 billion dollars with a big
the accusation was that credit card
companies had colluded with banks to
engage in anti-competitive activities
which allowed them to raise fees higher
than normal on credit card purchases
without letting the little coffee shops
of the world raise their prices to a
competition to the payout with lawsuit
change just that it allowed merchants to
raise their prices to accommodate credit
card fees the thinking was that if they
could do this and make it dissuade more
people from using credit cards and the
credit card companies would be forced to
bring the transaction fees stand but
with the whopping 68 percent of all
credit card purchases coming from Visa
and MasterCard that maybe a pipe for
maybe you can understand why a lot of
small businesses don't accept credit
cards they can't afford it and they have
to hope that people like me will go out
and get the cash instead of going
somewhere else like Starbucks who can
handle the fees and I would do it too I
get real money the problem is that the
ATM next door to the coffee shop it
charges me 250 to take out cash
fifty-two books
52 weeks 52 books 52 weeks if you follow
me on tumblr I will feel bad about not
reading the books if I don't read them
so that's why you should follow me
because you are the ones that are gonna
help me finish all these books support
small business